good is not funny
because it's not funny it's just not
funny
but the bad thoughts
the bad thoughts are funny because
they're unexpressed yeah you know
and so I'm kind of
um
letting these thoughts that go
unexpressed that we all have
all the time yeah
um oh gee look at this morning what am I
going to say to this mourner you know oh
Jesus Christ I got to talk to the
mourner now I can't talk to mourners you
know
I don't like talking to mourners you
but we all got to go talk to that
morning we don't want to right we're
afraid in the morning right yeah
I'm so sorry yeah and you feel like an
idiot even saying it you don't know how
you don't know how to behave anyway we
all have these thoughts that's just one
little thing yeah but there's thousands
of those that we all deal with all the
time